Kourtney Kardashian sets the record
straight on you and Benjamin so that's
your boyfriend here's how it all went
down on Monday the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star was spotted hanging out
with the model in Malibu California
marking the first time they'd been seen
together since their split in August
after nearly two years together a report
later surfaced that Kourt sisters Kim
and Khloe thought use tipped paparazzi
off about the meeting in an attempt to
squeeze out the last drops of his 15
minutes of fame there's just too much
going on on Wednesday Kourt slammed the
report tweeting fake news a source tells
et that court and Yoon's have remained
in contact since ending their
relationship adding quote the two caught
up recently and talked about their
breakup and relationship and where they
stood according to the source they both
feel they had a great relationship and
are figuring out if it's worth figuring
out what is next for them I have no
ideas in God's hands a source previously
told ETS that their age gap ultimately
played a factor in their splits 39 year
old Kourtney and 25 year old Yoon's met
during Paris Fashion Week in 2016 he was
friends with our friends okay he would
walk in like say hi shake hands with
like our security or whatever but like
not say hi to us and then I was like why
do you hate us like I was just drunk oh
my god once I said that he literally
grabbed my hand it was like it's 5:00 in
the morning we're leaving and the next
night mewn so as I bring your ass here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]